10 Sox okay now I've got my five pairs
different colors different letters okay
now let's just consider this from a
permutations point of view okay and the
first thing you've got to notice is if
you want permutations then order matters
remember I head of this ordered
selections okay
so therefore like at the moment at the
present time I can't tell the difference
between these two socks
but if order matters I need to be able
to tell the difference you know suppose
like like with me
one of one of my blue socks has a hole
in it okay so I actually can't tell the
difference between them automatic to
show that on here I'm just going to call
these a 1 a 2 they won't be two you get
the idea so now I have 10 completely
unique socks okay now I want a pair
don't I I want a pair on any given
morning right and I have tend to choose
from
I want the pair and I have 10 to choose
from now which which number is which
it's actually pretty clear I mean n
always has to be bigger than K in all
ways that's a bigger because otherwise
what would this be it's like 2 minus 10
factorial okay so your big numbers
always here your little numbers always
here so how many ways are there to get a
pair out of this how many permutations
the answer is 10 P to whatever that is
okay actually it's not that hard to work
out but that's my point
okay the calculator can work that out
now out of those 10 P 2 permutations
that's my sample space how many of them
are the ones that I actually want how
many of them are favorable well there
are so few I can list them out I'll give
you an example a 1 a 2 thumbs up that's
a match give me another one
I before you go on don't forget that
order matters right
so before you move on to be cut I had
them in the reverse order
it's another patch right and then I can
go well now I can go on to the bees and
I can get them in Reverse and I don't
need to go that far to see that there
are 10 of these permutations that will
give me a match 10 permutations now you
can reach for your calculator and do
this but I happen to know that it's
mighty right it's 1 over 9 right no
probability tree is required so can you
see you've got all these tools in your
arsenal right and being able to do a
probability question is number one
knowing them all well enough to use them
and then picking them out at the right
time